WIL WILLIS: The trench knife
was developed for US World War I
troops in need of
a versatile weapon
to employ in the hand-to-hand
combat they faced
while raiding enemy trenches.
Featuring a pointed blade
and four-fingered guard,
or knuckle duster, the
weapon was used for stabbing,
slashing, and punching.
The solid steel knuckle
duster prevented enemies
from seizing the knife and could
be used like brass knuckles
to issue devastating blows.
Your knives must include
an integral handle
made from the same piece
of steel as the blade.
You must include
four finger holes.
You will have four hours
in which to complete this,
but only one of you can be
working the steel at a time.
So we will rotate at
30 minute intervals.
Apprentices, you're up first.
Your four hour foraging
time starts now.
Get it back in there.
Go find some bigger tongs.
We're so used to foraging
against the clock being
in horse show contests--
There you go!
That's kind of old
rap for us, I think.
It's fun.
RALEIGH: Yeah, it's fun.
It's what we do for fun.
Hey, can you block that
side up a little bit?
KELLY: Yeah, I can.
And then open up
your tools here?
Am I being too bossy?
KELLY: No, no, keep talking?
RALEIGH: Follow their footsteps.
You gotta let it prep.
There!
Yeah!
I see a lot of intense
coaching from Raleigh.
There you go!
Yeah!
[laughter]
That's [bleep] awesome.
WIL WILLIS: Switch!
Kelly got us pretty
well-sorted out.
Now, it's my job to do something
about these finger holes.
Because I'm not real
sure about them.
I've never made any.
I'm going to just drift them in.
- Whoo!
Yes, ma'am!
Yeah, I got your back!
And then we'll file them
and grind them into shape.
Nice.
Look at rally hammer.
You got a farrier
with a vengeance.
I just wanted
to hit something.
WIL WILLIS: Switch!
Half your time has
already elapsed.
Make sure you got it
real secure in there, Kel.
Start grinding that [bleep].
Hoo-wah, she's
already on the grinding.
KELLY: I need a band-aid.
RALEIGH: Going good?
KELLY: Yeah, I'm good.
I just need a band-aid.
Uh-oh.
Whoa.
That's a lot of blood.
It's not a cut.
It's a tear.
We've got the medic coming in.
No, no, I don't have time.
No, no it's not [inaudible].
Please, no.
The grinder attacked me.
[laughter]
Just give me a
band-aid right there.
That's all I need.
It's not bad.
Kelly over there,
it looks like she
messed up her finger pretty bad,
and she's still trying to work.
KELLY: I don't want
to leave the floor.
It was just a little bitty cut.
I broke my foot in four places
and shod 10 horses afterward.
I just need to keep working.
I don't have time.
I don't have time for this.
- All right.
Thanks.
We don't worry about little
flesh wound around here.
It's all good.
Switch!
RALEIGH: Kelly,
we better [bleep]
hope that we can rasp this.
We should have checked.
I'm grinding on this
blade and all of a sudden,
I start thinking, this
blade's pretty hard.
We might be in trouble.
Because I'm not sure our
plan to rasp out these holes
is going to go as
easily as planned.
KELLY: I should have
punched them bigger.
We underestimated the work
hardness of a [inaudible]..
Hand rasping is not easy.
RALEIGH: If we don't get these
finger holes sorted out so
that the judges can
fit their fingers in,
we're going to have a problem.
WIL WILLIS: 5, 4,
3, 2, 1, bladesmen,
shut down your machines.
Drop your tools.
This first round of
competition is over.
That was fun.
Masters and apprentices,
it's time for the judges
to take a look at your work.
Raleigh, Kelly, please, present
your blade to the judges.
That's a heck of a knife.
I don't see any kind
of cracking or problems
with the steel itself.
But the big thing is these
holes are pretty small.
I would really like to see these
holes opened up a little bit.
No one swings hammers
like farriers do.
But remember one of these
tests is a stab test,
and that's a very
wide point for a stab.
WIL WILLIS: Joe, Casey,
your team's up next.
Man, that's an
aggressive design.
It's just really intimidating.
All in all, I think
you did a great job.
Well done.
WIL WILLIS: Tyler and
Leon, you guys are up next.
In the competition where the
defining part of this design
is all about the
handle, it's unfinished.
I can't even get my fingers to
make it workable at this stage,
and that's very important.
WIL WILLIS: It's time for one
of you teams to leave the fore.
Leon and Tyler, your blade
did not make the cut.